よし
取りますかこんにちははじめ社長ですこの動画のタイトルにもあります通り
ああ最後まで見て下さいお願いします
これそういう奴なんであのこの動画タイトルにもあるんですけども
必ず2回見てほしいんですよこれにはちゃんと理由がございましてですね
私の動画のここ1カ月間の平均再生回数を見てみましょう
830日前1か月前に出したら動画鮮度の鉄球を1人分だけたらどうなるのっている
動画なんですけどもここから30日間動画の平均再生回数はまずだしますそれじゃ
大雑把にちょっと調べますね
過去30日間に10本の動画を出しました豪邸再生回数が45201万2000回再生
です
20本でこれから生成回数これを破る20すると1本あたりの平均再生回数が226万
600回再生なんですよ
をうん
何かヤバいか分かるんですけど中にはすごい伸びた動画末端でばらつきあるものの僕の
平均ここ議決ねいや220万回戦生ぐらいということは平均的には僕220万回再生の
再生されるんですよでそれでも見てくださる方が220万に入るとしてさらに動画の中
でもタイトルにもさまでにもあるんですけど私が2回みて下さいお願いしますって
ミュート再生回数は2倍になるのかどうかという検証でございますよ
水玉リボン土っぽい反応するぜ純正に行ってみたかったんですうん前に行ってみたかっ
たからあのならであの強制はしません
こんなたくさんね月ベグはしゃべってるドアの見なくなるんで簡潔にまとめましょう皆
さん2回見てくださいそうすればきっとこの動画の再生回数が220万の2倍などで
440万海再生になんているはずでございますアンぜひ見てってください
やっぱやることなほんとそれだけなんですでもこれうまくいったら youtube の
皆さんぜひやまあ一回しか
できたやつを言ってください絶対に外に出って言ったら後最近の平均再生回数の2倍の
再生数が体に揺られるんでわかりませんけど
チョコ寿司苦痛に霊獣した決勝でも見せて終わるかホント申し訳ないマジで自粛中でも
ピアノっとイントルード県な割ちょっとってつけたんですけどちょっと
ぜひ
見えてくださいちょっとこれしか見えん
どうぞ
[音楽]
me
うざん
あんなに見せてるんだろうれあーやー
ないようなに動画ですままたまだのたったたまにはいいと思ったんですよ400
ちょっとずつねその自粛とか
禁術対戦が歳以上されてきて全然まだ安心はできないですけども日朝が戻ってくるわけ
なんですけどもみなさんたくさんや進みましたよ
これどういう意味かといいますと夏休みの前借りなんですよ
そうです我々が休んだり家にいた時間
多分なんですけども普通に行くとこのままだとこれでなんて安いもん休むとほとんど
授業を休んでいることになって本当に進まなくなるんで多分夏休みなくなると思うん
ですよね
我々は夏休みの前鍵をしてるんですよねこれでの街ユーチューバーの皆さんにとっても
ショックの話なんですよこれね8月とかって夏休みでたくさん動画を見てもらえるよう
なイメージがあるんですけどそれが今年は何を破った俺
言われ you to bar にとっても夏休み名前が入っていうのはちょっと怖い
んですよね実は
う
何の話ししてんだろレギュラーの本音だねじゃあ3-2回再生してください
[音楽]
じゃ
ほんとこれだけだから子へメッ
あっは
[音楽]
blr